hello my children it's time to grab your
voodoo dolls and make a smoothie because
it's the latest episode of American
Horror Story apocalypse and this one is
lit the episode begins in the pre
apocalypse timeline where Dyna uses a
voodoo doll to rip a hole through one of
her victims she rips out her heart and
that makes it two episodes in a row with
hearts ripping out Dyna has a nice
little side business using her dark
magic for financial gain the woman who
hired her wanted her husband's mistress
to feel the pain but judging by this
opening scene it's almost as if she's
under a spell willingly taking off her
top for her Dyna and her new friend make
a delicious heart smoothie incorporating
toenails for that extra kick they
force-feed him the concoction and Dyna
gets on top of him looking like she's
enjoying it a little too much after
she's done she refers to herself as the
voodoo queen of boasting that she can
make any problem go away she's made it
so that his dick won't get hard for
anyone but his wife now that's love Dyna
is confronted by Cordelia and we learned
she took over as voodoo queen from Marie
Laveau you might remember her from
season 3 played by Angela Bassett the
voodoo queen is essentially the
equivalent of the supreme for its voodoo
practitioners she's moved from New
Orleans to California where all the
wealthy rich folk are saying the only
thing that matters in this world isn't
black or white it's green Cordelia wants
a meeting with Papa Legba the gatekeeper
of the spirit world you may recall that
Marie Laveau sold her soul to Papa Legba
in order to acquire immortality in
exchange TS Marie for the annual
sacrifice of an innocent life at any
time of his choosing
Dinah tells Cordelia she must be
desperate if she wants to talk with the
voodoo devil but ultimately agrees to
set up a meeting for $100,000 cash then
were introduced to the delightful
bubbles McGee who guts her husband on
Christmas Eve oh wow that rhymed it's
all shot in an 80s slasher style and if
you remember from episode 1 when Joan
Collins played Nana Evie that she was
married to a Hollywood studio exec
things don't go over well for bubbles
when the Santa she turns away from the
door turns out to be the D cap
tation killer it looks like she's on
Santa's naughty list since she gets a
bunch of decapitated heads down the
chimney worst Christmas ever but not to
worry since we're on the set of a
Hollywood movie and bubbles is totally
safe except from the comments of lewd
crewmembers she gets from reading their
minds then there's a diva-off between
Madison and bubbles we learned she left
the coven to hone her craft of being an
actress and if there's one thing that
pisses Madison off it's making fun of
her failed movie career bubbles has been
summoned the witches need all the help
they can get if they're going to fight
the evil of Michael Langdon and evil we
learn more about last episode when
Madison and behold visited Murder House
bubbles Madison and Myrtle enjoy a fancy
dinner when bubbles demonstrates her
power of lectio animaux the ability to
listen to someone's very soul its
literal translation from Latin means
mind-reading with their power she'll be
able to read Ariel's mind and
potentially Michael's the issue isn't
only Michael however but the warlocks
who protect him they want bubbles to
come back with them to Hawthorne to find
out what Ariel knows and what he is
planning Dinah warns Cordelia about Papa
Legba he never reneged on his bargain if
she can't deliver on what she promises
there will be hell to pay
she then performs a voodoo ritual
reciting the incantation in French now
for something story facts shout-out to
Madame Lipton who taught me grade 9
French Dinah says open the barrier for
me and lo and behold Papa Legba appears
looking like a 1990s wrestling character
he drinks the concoction Dinah prepared
for him a mixture of rum and other
Voodoo materials
she's also prepared a Cohiba Cuban cigar
which was fun fact Fidel Castro's
favorite brand apparently he thinks
Dinah has summoned him to reconsider his
offer if she snatches newborns from the
maternity ward he'll grant her
immortality a price which Dinah was and
is unwilling to pay he also refers to
her as a mambo which is the term used
for our female high priest in the Voodoo
religion which is a real religion by the
way Papa Legba seems to already know why
Cordelia's here referring to Michael
Langdon as the Antichrist the bringer of
the end of days he doesn't think he can
help saying he's merely a gatekeeper
between humanity and
underworld then Cordelia unveils her
plan have Papa Legba opened the gates to
the underworld and banishing Michael
they're doomed to roam the underworld
for eternity she just has to name her
price but before we can get to that
we're surprised with nan yes ladies and
gentlemen it's our beloved nan who is
sacrificed to Papa Legba by Fiona and
Marie Laveau in season 3 she apparently
is loving hell becoming Papa's favorite
Little Helper
if Cordelia can supply a soul to Papa
he'll consider this coup against the
Lord of Darkness but he doesn't want one
soul he wants all of them all of the
girls souls from the witches coven
Cordelia protests demanding he take hers
after all she is the most powerful witch
on earth but Papa is firm this is his
final offer
Cordelia isn't willing to make that
offer and Papa disappears she pleads to
Dinah there must be another way but
she's had her chance and blew it now not
only will all her girls die but the six
other billion people on the planet
back at the coven Mallory asked Queenie
and Zoe when Michel will officially
become supreme and this transition
apparently happens when the old one dies
but they're interrupted by Coco who has
found a new power she's a walking
nutrition guide it's also fun to see the
change dynamic between Coco and Mallory
here Coco no longer being a [ __ ] but
excited and empowered by Mallory's
positive outlook but this fun moment is
short-lived when Coco chokes on a
snowball and falls unconscious
Mallory using her restorative powers
which we saw her perform in episode 5 on
the deer opens up Coco's neck to
dislodge the snowball saving her life
Zoe's astonished at Mallory's power
claiming she's never even heard of a
spell like that this works on my theory
that I elaborated on in my episode 5
video that Mallory isn't a witch but may
be some sort of angel or Nephilim
Cordelia stumbles on the stairs looking
like she's starting to lose her powers
if you remember from episode 5 she's
already told Myrtle that she's dying and
that nasty ass growth in her stomach
can't be good she confides in Zoe saying
that she can't possibly fight Michael in
her condition but Zoe offers a glimmer
of hope saying the reason Cordelia is
fading isn't Michael it's Mallory at the
warlock school or outpost 3 as we've
come to know it Myrtle place
beautiful music on a theremin and look
bubbles has a glass of champagne which
we know Nana evey so desperately loved
back in Episode one they've come to
apologize to Ariel and Baldwin but
really we know they're there to read
Ariel's mind bubbles introduces herself
for marking they may have seen her on
one of those CBS procedurals
which is pretty funny since the reaction
shot of this is of BD Wong who has been
on to CBS procedurals
Madam Secretary and Law & Order SVU at
dinner
Ariel tells The Witches that Michael has
gone into the wilderness if Michael is
the Antichrist he may be following the
same path as Christ who also went into
the desert wilderness for 40 days and
was confronted by the devil bubbles
reads their minds and let's just say it
isn't good Baldwin wants to wipe the
smiles off their faces and Ariel can't
wait until every last one of them is
dead it's implied here that Myrtle puts
a spell on the two warlocks telling them
it's been getting late of which they
both agree bubbles tells Myrtle that the
warlocks murdered one of their own
referring of course to John Henry who
was burnt to a crisp by Michaels satanic
foster mom in episode 5 this fight
between witches and warlocks is just
getting started and it's kill or be
killed back of the coven the witches
have dinner and they all seem to have
accepted the fact that Mallory will
ascend as leader of the witches to take
on Michael Mallory isn't too keen to
take over from Cordelia but there's
still much to be done and look who's
also there behold who has arrived back
from murder house with Madison he gives
a passionate speech saying that he and
the warlocks were wrong to give rise to
Michael saying that they now must stop
him were then shown Cordelia performing
a sacred ritual two years ago before the
apocalypse
chanting ash and soul arise from the
fire returned to me then it's revealed
this was how Myrtle was brought back
from the dead
Cordelia needed her guidance for the war
to come no matter the cost and insert
badass slow-motion which shot the
witches arrived at the gas station and
something tells me it's not for the
cheap prices zoe uses her powers to
bring back John Henry's ashes then
Cordelia tells Mallory to bring him back
this in effect will become her seventh
wonder if you remember in episode 5
Michael faced a similar challenge
dissension in which he was tasked to
bring
stay back from the dead she's successful
in the witches are told the awful truth
that he was betrayed by Ariel and
Baldwin he tells them he was killed by a
woman Michaels satanic mom
Cordelia tasks Koko with taking her out
she follows me to the butchers and she
shot but before Meade can finish the job
she's grabbed by two of the coven's
thugs and Koko is whisked away back at
outpost three Baldwin has perfected a
powder that will kill any woman who
inhales it then there's a series of
gruesome shots of the coven witches
succumbing to agonizing deaths at the
hands of the warlocks but their plan is
cut short when the witches arrive
Cordelia tells them the witch who
actually perfected this powder was Agnes
Sampson back in the 1500s this was a
real person who was burnt at the stake
in Scotland for supposed healing powers
she destroys the powder an Ariel tells
her her powers have already waned but
Cordelia doesn't like that one bit she
performs Perpetuum closest or always
closed which shuts their mouths even
with her powers waning she is still the
superior witch Ariel Baldwin and
Michael's satanic foster mom are brought
to the stake and doused in gasoline
but since tradition states no witch may
kill a condemned warlock that honor
falls on John Henry and in a moment of
sweet irony John Henry kills me the same
way she killed him in gasoline and
flames but Meads last words are somewhat
prophetic saying the flames will cleanse
her like the flames will cleanse the
world hinting at the apocalypse to come
she makes a plea to father the devil
saying kingdom is near before she's
burned smiling as it happens and off
their burning corpses the episode ends
this episode didn't do much to advance
the main plot but it did set up a lot of
stuff to come the witches are preparing
for the war and they've started with
taking down Michael's closest allies but
with Michael being in the wilderness it
may be a while before he finds out and
when he does he's gonna be hella pissed
but what we do know is that the witches
plan against Michael fails and the next
few episodes will probably see how it
does so not to mention how Cordelia puts
her protection spells on Dinah koko and
mallory before the apocalypse will
Michael come back from the wilderness
even stronger and will Mallory have
enough time to harness her powers and
become a formidable enough opponent to
him
whatever the case is it looks like we'll
have a battle of The Supremes to look
forward to
I hope you enjoyed this video please
like and subscribe with the bell on and
if you didn't I have a delicious
smoothie for you to try I also have a
Twitter where you can get my latest
updates and I'm hoping to test out the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina next to
see if that would be a good series to do
if you think so leave me a comment below
and last but not least you know I can't
leave without saying it daddy loves you
very much